alright I'm here to talk about es
modules in electron sorry no I'll do
this one on web layouts which will work
in electron so that's great because I've
never actually built anything in
electron so sorry I do use it every day
I scrolled down farther on the website
and was like oh yeah I use that one in
that one and those and yeah okay I use
that every day I run a full stack
consulting agency called odd bird I do a
lot of CSS and interface
you know like front-end development but
the other kind there's also I mean I've
seen if you're interested I've seen this
other great talk on CSS in electron
native eise's the new normalize go check
it out online that's the end of my talk
I'm gonna talk about CSS layout if you
don't know I built Susy which is a grid
system which is why I get to talk about
this thing and I'm here to tell you not
to use it at the end cool any questions
to him all right so we're gonna go back
in history 1993 we got HTML you might
have heard of it it's a markup language
this was me starting my company in 93
with my brothers I think we're doing a
card sort there ignore them Magic the
Gathering 1997 we got tables this was
the first way that we started to lay out
on the web
lots of fun everybody loves tables and
if nobody's yelled at you recently
tables are in fact for data they have
very limited styling options there's not
a lot you can do with them because
they're built for laying out data they
have very strict nonlinear markup which
makes them inaccessible which is a
problem both for SEO and for your
lawyers so it's just an accessibility
nightmare
and there's a lot of problems with that
but we all know that we've already moved
past that part of that problem is that
code is communication I quote Sarah
Dresner saying that but she always
reminds me she only said it once I just
happened to be there
they destroy meaning table layouts
destroy our ability to make meaning out
of the code they're you they're not
semantic they don't mean anything and
they just add confusion in mm well
technically in 1996 but not in any
browsers until 2000
we got cascading style sheets which are
designed with this principle of least
power that's a core design feature so if
you're worried about the lack of power
I'll show you that we have lots more
power now but from the beginning CSS was
designed to have less power and that's a
feature and that's a good thing you've
all seen this this is also a feature if
your design tool didn't allow you to do
overflow you would be pissed so this is
absolutely part of any good design
language but don't be fooled
CSS has a declarative syntax which makes
it not programming to some people but it
is not a static language it has loss of
dynamic power there's a lot you can do
with it so we're gonna dig into some of
that part of what we want to do when
building layouts CSS is designed to
establish dynamic relationships between
things because we're dealing with a
dynamic page we have to have a language
that is designed to create dynamic
layouts so how is this interface going
to change when the content changes when
the viewport changes when the context
changes we've got all these sort of
dynamic variables that we don't know and
we have to have a language that sets up
relationships so that we can handle that
you've maybe seen this this is like a
third of the different devices people
are using to access your well you know
if you're using electron maybe it's not
all of these cool but we're not just
designing for one guy with yellow hair
we're designing for all these people and
then all these people and then all these
people and all those different browsers
and we need to make it work everywhere
that's part of the vision
the web and electron is part of the web
so one of the rules that we're going to
follow always in building a layout is
that we pay attention to the flow the
flow goes in two directions
so here's block flow elements stack up
in blocks down the page and we can go to
an inline flow and then they stack up
next to each other and we can mix and
match those and the nice thing about
flow is we have relationships when one
thing changes other things change and
that's great because we're dealing with
a dynamic page we want to keep those
relationships in place so staying in the
flow helps us do that I'm gonna look a
little bit keeping that in mind at some
of the classic layout techniques and how
we got where we are how we got to grid
systems and Susy and how we got past
them so the first thing when I started
using CSS I was like I want to do
layouts position is probably the answer
or right that would make sense it
doesn't make any sense when you position
something relative it just moves it this
is very much like what we have
transforms for now but it has no effect
on the flow of everything around it so
that breaks our rules the layout using
that for layout doesn't affect the flow
not useful position:absolute same thing
it's a little bit different it takes it
out of the flow completely not useful
for layout because if we did a layout
entirely with absolute positioning which
I've seen people do everything is it
feels like you're removing the
connections between things but in
reality you're making more connections
because if you change the size of one
thing you're gonna have to change the
sizes and layouts of everything else
because all those numbers are related so
absolute are fixed they work great for
overlays things that aren't actually
part of the layout that come in over top
off canvas menus
drop downs tooltips things like that
that come in over top of the layout but
aren't part of it so the first thing we
got though actually became useful was
floats which is a hack but a fun hack
it's really great for floating things in
text that's what it's for
it does it really well but when you
start to do layouts you run into some
problems so you can see that the
container around it is not moved only
the text and other floats move around it
so it's sort of in the flow and sort of
out of the flow and doesn't make a whole
lot of sense
we're getting close if we really want it
to work we need to clear fix this is a
small one you can do it as a class or a
mixin or however you like and as soon as
you add the clear fix basically we're
just adding something down below that
would be hidden and that makes
everything not everything but some
things clear around it so there's
different hacks if you add
overflow:hidden to it suddenly
everything will float around it which is
another weird little hack that's super
useful until you need to overflow we're
getting this display flow route except
that no browsers are implementing it I
think it is implemented in one or two
places I didn't check whether electron
is one of those may be worth looking
into this is the official syntax for a
clear fix if you want to stop using the
hack the great thing about floats the
thing that I miss about them is how
flexible the markup and nesting is when
I float something I can count on
everything collapsing and that's kind of
nice if javascript is giving me all
these extra divs nested divs that I'd
never wanted they can just disappear
because floats ignore them that was nice
unfortunately floats don't have a good
sense of the context they're not
entirely in the flow so we end up with
these explicit widths and explicit
relationships that don't flow together
so it's not the
first hack it worked for us for a while
but we had some other options display
table came along some people got really
excited about that it's interesting so
here's something some divs that are
stacked up in blocks and then when I
changed them to a table they lay out
like a table and it has a lot of the
same limitations as HTML tables in terms
of styling but it also does give us sort
of ways of taking up space on a single
line it's one line at a time like a
table would be columns and rows so some
interesting power there also some
limitations like you can't use margins
on them you have to use border padding
which is not a property most people use
very often but works it's again not a
terrible hack around 2007 to 2010 we
started getting the major grid
frameworks basically it's this we've got
12 columns they go in a single direction
there's no vertical grid there's just
the horizontal grid we want to span
things on that grid so we want to take
an element and say okay span six of our
12 columns and generally the way they
were done the first ones like blueprint
I think was one of the first you add a
margin on one side usually on the right
and that's your gutter and then you have
this problem at the end where you need
to get rid of the gutter on the last
element because that would be extra and
so everybody has this class syntax that
says you know column this is a column
it's going to be 6 of 12 and this is the
last one so take off that final gutter
and that's nice enough classes work as
an API classes are the main API built
into CSS if you're building an API
that's one of the ways you're gonna do
it
when 960 came along they proposed this
sort of split gutters approach where you
get half a gutter on either side of the
grid and you get half gutters on either
side of every element and they stack up
to create full gutters
and that was clever because suddenly we
didn't have to deal with the last and
that part could go away and everything
could just be consistent but still we're
working in the same systems these are
nice especially at the time when we were
dealing with so many hacks these
provided us with some consistent
patterns to use when doing a layout and
they allowed developers to ignore CSS
which is great and also they allowed
developers to ignore CSS which is
terrible
so pluses and minuses there they also
provided a sort of one-size-fits-all
solution especially at the beginning
everybody gets 12 columns everybody
decides how to lay out on those 12
columns with something like 960 it was
even built in the exact width that
everybody should use is 960 pixels and
that was the idea so one-size-fits-all
solutions don't really make the web very
interesting around that time this is
when I was actually starting my company
I saw this video this is still a talk
worth watching if you write CSS there
are parts of it that are out of date but
a lot of it is just really smart ways of
thinking about CSS this is Natalie down
gave us in BarCamp London CSS systems
and she was proposing that rather than
having one library of classes that we
put on every site we have ways of
thinking about layout that we can take
from one project to the next we have
similar naming conventions so this would
be like these days we talk about smacks
and BEM and oo CSS our naming
conventions so she was proposing that
early on that you figure out your own
naming conventions you figure out your
way of doing layout and take that from
project to project part of what made
this attractive to me is that this is
the right system for people who are
doing agency work where we're moving
quickly from one project to the next if
I was building one project over the
course of 15 years the class API the
library might make more sense to me
so there's trade-offs there I'm not male
force I'm not insta slack so it's
needs four different people there's not
one right answer but I liked her system
she was basically saying systems for
doing it rather than frameworks for
doing it we want fluid grids on the
outside or fluid grids in how we define
everything relationships and then we can
put static containers on them if we want
to and the nice thing was that then you
can make changes quickly and say okay I
want it bigger and you don't have to
change everything
all the internals are built fluid and
just move it was a very clever system it
was sort of responsive before responsive
and I really liked it but the math was
really ugly and I was really sitting
there with a calculator on one side of
the screen and my code on the other and
just copying and pasting in these
numbers and they're terrible I have no
idea what that means it all comes from
this you take the the target the span
that you want you divide it by the
context and you get the multiplier and
that's how all of this grid math works
in SAS you can mimic that with just
percentage target divided by context
that should be simple like 1/5 would
give you 1/5 of the columns but it's not
simple because gutters get in the way so
gutters make it complex and you end up
with this math which I was doing and SAS
came well Seth started to get some
traction right around that time and
that's what Suzy came out of so in 2009
I made Suzy and the basic idea was let's
just take that math and make it readable
great you still don't want to use it the
nice thing is it gives you any grid
system on demand the sad part is it's
usually overkill you usually don't need
it especially now so yeah don't use it
have I been clear on that
great so one thing that you can do now I
think it was around 2007 that we got box
sizing to change the box model that
really allows you to move gutters to the
inside of elements and really simplify
the math so then your grid looks like
this
and you put your spacing inside
the math is just fractions this is
actually what Nicole Sullivan do it was
doing an oCSS right away even before you
could put the padding on those elements
she did it by added adding a nested a
nested element to do the padding but if
you fix the box model which this is one
of the things that I II got right the
first time and the rest of us are
catching up the default box model is
this when you set width and height in
CSS you're setting the width and height
of the content and then padding is on
top of that and then border is on top of
that and then margins on top of that and
that doesn't make sense for most of the
way we think about layouts it only makes
sense sometimes when we're defining a
container for something and we want the
inner width that can be useful but not
very often
so this is what we really want and now
we can set it with border box box model
and then we set the height and width and
everything is subtracted from that and
that's gonna be much more useful and
that allows us to set it with and then
add padding and the padding doesn't
change what the width is so if you want
global box sizing I start every project
with this line of code which is just hey
everything should have the box sizing of
border box that's a great way to do it
I've seen this approach and I don't
recommend it the HTML box sizing border
box and then everything inherits from
that there's a reason that we don't
inherit margins and backgrounds and
padding and layout features this is a
layout feature it shouldn't be inherited
I want to be able to change it somewhere
and not have that change trickle down
the idea behind this was that it helps
you create blocks for old or code to fit
into you can still do that you can
create a block that uses the old box
model but don't do that globally so part
of avoiding tightly coupled elements
this is a thing that we talk about in
terms of components it's also something
that we want in terms of keeping those
relationships fluid and moving we want
to avoid tightly coupling so we don't
get changes I
think that slide was out of order didn't
that seem out of order that seemed out
of order to me okay so in 2011 we got
calc calc is really cool and it's super
supported if you aren't using it yet
we've had it for a long time you can
start to mix units in CSS which was
always a pain point so now we can start
playing with how do percentages and
pixels stack up together and then in
2012 we got flex back yeah yeah we did
I'm just gonna let you think about that
while I take a drink so flex box is cool
and it was a good start it does it gives
us lots of power so here's some things
stacking up right now I have them
wrapping I can tell them not to wrap and
then they'll try to all fit on the same
line you can do vertical centering like
I'm doing here I can change it from a
row to a column I can change it to
column reverse and they go up instead of
down there's all sorts of things I can
do like that I can have things out of
order you can see three is out of order
because I've set an order on it there's
lots that we can do with flexbox but one
of the problems is that it still keeps
relationships each each element defines
its own width which can be problematic
sometimes for a layout we get this sort
of global flow where the parent element
says what direction things should go are
they going column a row are they going
forward or backwards but then individual
they're individually sized each element
determines its own size so you still
don't have this sort of defining a
context of a layout and then putting
things into place instead you're
defining on each element where it needs
to go and what size it needs to be and
that means that you're still tightly
coupled so it's great when we only want
to flow in one direction or another but
it's not as great when we want layouts
grow and shrink do give us some ability
to define relationships they change how
things should expand or can
tract to fill extra space or not enough
space but nesting matters a lot things
are only flex when they are in a Flex
container and there's no way of saying
this should be a flex element of its
grandparent ancestor which i think is
limiting we're going to get tools for
that but they're not available yet and
it at a page level it has poor
performance because of that aspect where
each element is defining its own layout
that means at a page level we get lots
of rewriting and that's not great so it
solved some problems but not everything
in 2014 we got CSS variables which I'll
show you how those are part of layout I
mean we had variables before if you
count current color variables look like
this they you define them they're
basically an empty prefix so we got a
browser prefix and there's no it's not
first visit browser it's for me and so
that's how we define variables and then
they can have any content in them
they're also called custom properties
because they're going to get a lot more
power soon that's all in the works to
call them we say we use a variable
function similar to the calc function
and we say what what the variable name
is and then we can provide fallbacks
anything after the first comma is a
fallback so you can't stack up fallbacks
but you can put something like a font
stack that has commas in it in the
fallback but this is if this property is
unfine will fall back to that value
which is you I think you can actually
then put in the fallback you can say
another variable and you can stack those
that way that doesn't work as fall backs
for browsers that don't support
variables because they won't understand
the whole line so that only works as a
fallback still for browsers that support
they're different from sass variable
sass variable scope to the file
structure so in sass if I define a
variable inside of the root selector it
is only of
available inside that specific route
selector it's not available inside a
nested class that will be inside of the
route it's not available at a media
query and then the route selector there
it's it's scopes to the file structure
the way that you would in JavaScript
which is not what we want for CSS
because that's not how CSS works so CSS
variables inherit instead of scoping so
when I define it in the root it is
defined everywhere and when I change it
at a media query it changes for that
element everywhere in that media query
so even if I defined a use for it
outside of the media query the value of
it will change when we hit that viewport
width and that's that makes more sense
for a lot of the things we're doing in
CSS
they also inherit everywhere by the no
they don't inherit everywhere by default
you can tell them to inherit everywhere
by having them defined on the root then
they will be available everywhere and if
you want them not to inherit you can say
every element should start with the
initial value and then these won't
inherit anymore you can create safe
inline styles with these you know inline
Styles have a very high selector
specificity there can be very hard to
override but if you need to pass in data
from JavaScript or from your server it
can be useful to pass in inline Styles
if you want to do that totally safely
you can pass them in as CSS variables
and they won't be used unless you use
them if you don't want to use them you
just ignore them and they don't do
anything so they have in that sense no
specificity because they don't do
anything so it's totally safe to pass in
data that way you can also use them to
avoid this sort of nesting I have button
and it's blue and then I have this
button is red instead of that I can say
buttons have a background of button
color which is defaults to blue and then
at this I can change it to red and
I've kept a single selector in both
places I'm not adding specificity every
time I want to change that so it's a
really handy way if I want an outer
element to change something on an inner
element I can just sort of do that
safely without increasing specificity if
I start to combine these toys calc with
variables I can very quickly build a
grid system in just a couple lines of
code and that's how it's used and I can
say I want to span three columns I want
to spend six columns and it's sort of
creating the mix in for itself and doing
it all internally to CSS no sass needed
I got crazy with this because I was like
what could it work could I rebuild Suzy
so I did I use a whole bunch of these
crazy properties each one doing one
thing to create Suzy and pure CSS and it
still supports all of Suzy's features
including generating that background
without ever using any sass don't use
that either that is also not worthwhile
basically you only need one layout Suzy
is built to handle all the layouts you
don't need something built to handle all
the layouts you need one layout so
another thing you can play with is
viewport units these give you things
like full height the the viewport height
would be the full screen you can do
sticky footers with a min height of the
100 vh VH basically works as a
percentage of the viewport you can break
out of the container by combining
percentages with viewport units and then
in 2017 we got jetpacks which is CSS
grid and it really landed in all of the
browsers over one weekend in 2017 all of
the browsers except ie
and it was it was like I left work on
Friday and it was unsupported anywhere
and I went back to work on Monday and it
was supported in the majority
the browsers we use and it really is
supported most places there is nothing
like it at all
if anybody claims that they are doing
what grid does it's not true if anybody
is saying that it's like tables that's
not true there is absolutely nothing
like it the spec can be very complex if
you try to read through it but there's a
lot of ways to get started very simply
it does give us truly two-dimensional
layouts not just 12 columns across and
it allows us to mix units so we can
define the template columns we can
define the template rows we can use
different units we can use this min max
to say it should be a minimum of one way
than a maximum of another width and it
will figure out what space is left we
have fraction units work similarly to
the grow and shrink values in flexbox
they allow you to dole up the remaining
space and we can quickly do this and
I'll just inspect it quick to show a lot
of dev tools especially Firefox have
ways of looking at a grid you can see
this grid is given numbered index lines
and you can layout on those lines I've
also given it named areas and then it's
negative one indexed if you want to lay
things out from the reverse there's a
lot you can do there
so laying things out by line we can do
layout from one line to another or we
can start at one line and span a certain
number or we can lay out two negative
numbers we get various options we can we
get global flow and sizing so everything
is defined in one place unless we pass
it back to the element with auto auto
says get the size from the element but
otherwise we can define it all in one
place which is handy we get these named
areas which are basically defined
using this ASCII art of our website
which is super handy because we can then
change the ASCII art somewhere and the
entire layout changes if we've defined
where we want what we want to be the in
the header block what we want to be in
the nav block and then we just change
the ASCII art at different sizes that
will all change I'll show you that so
let's inspect this again and look at the
grid and then change those sizes so
these things are laid out to header nav
main and footer and below a certain
width we changed the ASCII art and they
just all line up in a column and we can
do that as many times as we need to to
create as many layouts as we need to for
those blocks
if you're getting confused at all
between percentages viewport widths and
fractions this is just a quick guide
they all work in a similar way but
percentages are relative to the parent
width viewport width is relative to the
viewport as a whole and fractions are
relative to available space so that's a
quick way of thinking about them one
fraction there's a little bit of a
gotcha with it when you say something
should be one fraction by default the
browser's understand that as min/max
Auto one fraction which means they will
grow and not shrink so you if you
actually want things to be able to
shrink as well as grow you have to say
that explicitly use min max zero one
fraction to say that so this last year
Jen Simmons announced that we are moving
past responsive web design we're now
talking about intrinsic web design and
what that means is that we can start
mixing fixed and fluid instead of always
doing fluid we have stages of
squishiness these are the four stages we
can have fixed elements fluid elements
using fractions fluid until fixed using
min Max or flex basis and then items
that are actually just using their
automatic flow which we can assign using
Auto so if suddenly we're mixing all of
these into a single layout which is
totally new for us we can start nesting
these contexts so nothing has to go away
I heard one teacher telling their
students never to use floats now they're
old
that's like never using tables even for
data which I remember when people did
that so we don't have to ditch any of
these they're all useful together we can
nest them together and keep using them
for their different use cases we can
expand and contract to content we have
justify we have wrap we have flex all
these different ways of handling how we
move based on the content and the space
available we can use media queries as
needed and I can show you a quick sample
of that actually on my slide tool here
if you change the sizes it automatically
figures out
this is just telling it the minimum and
mathema more each slide it automatically
figures out how many columns we need
without any breakpoints the browser is
just doing that itself so media queries
are becoming only necessary in certain
situations and then we can start playing
with data-driven layouts I just had this
idea we were working on a new project
for a client and I thought well what
happens if I just pass in some of the
data we're trying to do a scheduling
tool and so I set up a grid that had a
grid column for every minute of the day
turns out you only get enough grid
columns for about 16 and a half hours
but that was enough and we just said it
in a start time and a duration for each
event and we immediately had a schedule
and it lays out and it even fills in the
gaps if we ask it to and all of that
just passing in those two values as CSS
custom properties then used directly by
grid so then I started playing with that
more I thought well okay we can do bar
charts and we can figure out how it
relates to the total value and so we've
got these bar charts that are totally
including the colors everything is
determined just by a total and a calc
and then I was like okay we got line
graphs that's something we might need so
I built line graphs that you know
generate some random data and then I was
like okay let's plot some things
generate that data with an XY and Z and
then I saw this piece of art and I was
like that's just some grids and some
generated variables so let's build that
add a few of these in and then go into
kick-ass battle mode and we can start to
shoot them because grid invaders so
that's important very very important I
would say
yeah if you want to find out more about
variables leav aru is a great source she
has some good talks online for grids
rachel andrew has grid by example which
gives not just examples but also common
templates and fallbacks for older
browsers and you can basically just copy
and paste my slides are all online and
I've tweeted them so you can find these
Jenn Simmons has layout land where she
gives lots of trainings on grids and
various other new toys and just remember
that CSS is awesome thank you
Thank You Miriam I kind of want to like
go straight into Q&A but can we just
like take a second to appreciate how
amazing Miriam's like highlight point or
thingy is I think completely lost track
of the slide because I was like what
[Music]
what is that it was amazing
it's the logitech spotlight oh look at
that
looky tack still doing cool start okay
all right
any questions for Miriam Wow oh the
slide link is down here if anybody needs
it also on Twitter um can I now make a
box with text the dynamic you fills the
box and scales it well so there are ways
that you can get close to that using
viewport units to set your font size if
you know the relationship between your
box and the viewport otherwise know
okay Oh is there any plans for ia to
support this as well what's that the
grid part for IU to support the good
part yeah we assume they're coming along
they just haven't yet I think it's
actually already supported an edge and
and ie
has an older implementation of it so
they have started but you know ie 10 11
will never quite catch up and it'll all
happen in edge but if you're using
electron everything is supported what
about people who are who are not going
to get that deep in CSS and I've played
with bootstrap and is this bootstrap a
particularly offensive framework or is
that a good place of starters there's
something that's better this so the only
operates some of this to kind of off the
shelf I I tried to figure out if I could
build a grid system around grids and
there's just no point
like grids if you figure out the basics
of grids it does what it does better
than anybody could build a framework
around it if you are using old
frameworks bootstrap is as fine as any
of them the main problem with bootstrap
is its popular and so all the sites look
the same and so do you consider that
offensive that's up to you flex box was
incredibly broken between browser
implementations in the beginning is CSS
grid more solid out of the box CSS grid
in my experience has been very solid
unless you're trying to port to the old
ie syntax and then there's quite a few
differences there but that's all behind
browser flags or properties so I haven't
seen major issues across Firefox Chrome
and the others
and Firefox announced yesterday that
their they've added animation of grid
properties so that's in Firefox nightly
as of I think yesterday do you have any
knowledge of where we're at with sub
grids
oh I it's everybody is asking for it
and it is what will make this perfect
nobody has implemented it yet so it
seems to be at the front of everybody's
minds and we don't know exactly when
somebody will actually launch it all
right with that we're gonna go into a
coffee break right because I definitely
need a coffee so we're all getting a
coffee that's the new rule we're going
to continue this party at 3:00 p.m. with
you no more talks about performance and
the last two talks for the day before we
open up the bar which I know it's like
what most of you actually here for but
until then we'll just have a little
coffee break and like a few snacks that
are being brought out just now so you
know energized it up Thank You Miriam
[Applause]